em'ly Joe Lovano Vic says dr. Petersen I
want to thank you I guess this isn't a
question for what you do I'm a 22 year
old girl and your videos are helping me
so much with figuring my life out you
are alone or helping me be braver every
day well I'm really happy about that you
know what I like your emphasis on
bravery you know because one of the
things that we've learned as clinicians
say is that when you help people
overcome anxiety it isn't that you make
them less anxious necessarily although I
think you could do that to some degree
by having people confront some of the
demons in their past but instead of
making them less anxious you make them
braver and that's not the same thing
right because there's lots of reason to
be anxious the world's full of
uncertainty and fear and reasons for
fear and reasons for pain but to be
braver means to confront those
voluntarily and that's really a good
thing when will the next Bible lecture
occur October 24th will be three of them
before the end of December and I want to
keep them going into the future they
they've been quite successful I would
say and I would like to go through the
whole book although that would probably
take me the rest of my life but I do
really think it's necessary because it
is the case that the specific narratives
and the meta-narrative that are that are
embedded in the biblical stories and its
surrounding literature are at the
fundament of Western culture and we need
to reconnect with that in order to make
sure that that our culture stays strong
and I don't think it's particularly
strong right now and that's a very bad
that's a very bad thing for everyone it
leads to nihilism and despair and and in
an ability to plan for a meaningful
future and cynicism and all of those
things and that's especially bad for
young people because when you're young
and your life is ahead of you it's the
last the last time that you need to be
nihilistic and cynical it's definitely
not good so